now republican lawmakers are bringing
the border crisis to doorsteps of
democrats including vice president
kamala harris herself two busloads of
migrants just pulled up right near her
d.c residence at the naval observatory
today they came courtesy of texas
governor abbott days after border czar
harris called our southern border quote
secure
meanwhile another republican governor
florida florida's ron desantis taking
similar action sending two plane loads
of illegal immigrants to martha's
vineyard you know that ritzy vacation
hot spot for wealthy liberals including
the obamas and oprah winfrey
democrats and the liberal media have
been blasting these moves vilifying the
governors as inhumane and racist and
even comparing it to the nazis
governor abbott's racist
and xenophobic practices of expulsion
have only amplified the challenges many
of these migrants have experienced on
their journey to find a safe place i
mean the conservative estimate is about
eighty thousand dollars per bus trip but
we know that you know races don't mind
paying this money so races you know are
willing to pay the money and they don't
care if taxpayers pay the brunt we woke
up to the news this morning that
governor ron desantis of florida sent
two plane loads of migrants
to martha's vineyard off the coast of
massachusetts and kids and whatnot and
i'm not saying this is not a one for one
this is not a parallel here in any way
but it does address some of the same
themes that are part of this documentary
some of the same themes tammy
to the holocaust racist and humane in
martha's vineyard but not at the
southern border how do they got off with
us yeah it's it's of course shock value
mentioning that moving people into that
dynamic to just to you know confuse them
the fact of the matter is it is this
rhetoric about sanctuary cities that
provides an incentive around the world
the word sanctuary it's powerful these
individuals from all over the world not
just south and central america but
certainly there have spent weeks if not
months in dangerous unknown
crazy you know
dynamics where children are abused where
there's sex trafficking where people
we've just seen a story
where we found traffickers
transporting people in suitcases and in
water barrels and these people who
created this incentive and who've made
it possible to make money like this on
the backs of human beings the littering
of the human bodies that we don't see
along this trail from the middle east
from asia from south and central america
creating this dynamic where people want
to go take that first step pay all their
money to get here and then suddenly the
first time they have actual secure
transportation to a city or to an
environment that portrays itself as this
is the place to come this is where you
will be safe and now they complain and
are condemned and it's considered an
assault on these cities what this is
revealed is the lie of what democrats
have said the danger that that rhetoric
has placed people in and then when
people
make it to this point they condem the
governors for trying to help facilitate
some level of safety and of course it
shows you that they've never intended
there to be sanctuary from the first
point it's always been about disrupting
the border and those red democr
republican gop states at the expense of
the lives of children of women who
remain enslaved in this country in part
due to uh having to pay back you know
the money they've they've taken to get
here with with uh you know some kind of
yeah they got to work it off they got to
work it off so yeah it exposes the lie
and and what it's done to human lives
it's shameful yeah and let's talk about
that hypocrisy for a second because i
feel like what you're saying to you're
pointing out that that condescension of
the left where they say
well look 50 people is fine says the
mayor of martha's vineyard we gave them
beds and we gave them health care he
said right patting himself on the back
for 50. but the overflowing thousands
that's ignored the vile conditions
currently in el paso which you've
covered extensively on your show the
smell of human waste littering the
streets because there is no space for
anyone that's ignored it's the cruelty
of compassion and the joke the mockery
that these dems make of their own little
villages because 50 is okay but 4 000
isn't that's when you declare a public
health state of emergency like mayor
bowser did well the democrat mayor of el
paso then put people on buses
because that was the reality that he no
longer wanted to live with he had to
tell his constituents eye to eye i'm
doing something about this you know
washington dc doesn't have to do that
because they can't see us and they keep
proving that over and over again and i
guess those people don't eat eggs
because the price of eggs is ridiculous
right now up 38 and going higher and i
only bring that in because as americans
are struggling to put food on the table
these are people who are going to need
to eat too
and they'll be eating up our tax dollars
and look we have the heart to take care
of them we will always be america
filled with americans
but these places as will kane told me
last year last hour these places these
these sanctuary cities and states
put out the invitation of come here and
tammy is so right they lied when they
did it that's right and you know what
now they have to prove to us that they
weren't lying that's right they got to
take all these people in and not only
just feed them but make their lives
better than when they got to the border
they got to prove that they're better
than republicans at what they're doing
but you know what they're doing muriel
bowser mayor of d.c begging for federal
help i need national guard i need money
i need all of this i need you know
meanwhile as you just said emily
i mean hundreds of thousands have been
taken in at the border that we know of
close to two million
by the end of the first fiscal year in
biden's presidency wow biden's america
and i'll ask you that same question
kaylee cause i can't wrap my head around
it why is it vile and inhumane for these
border mayors and and border governors
to help spread out to try to account for
the resources being deluded on their end
it's violent humane for them to spread
that love but it's not vile and humane
to have the poorest southern border be
open like an absolute tidal wave that
subjects all of these migrants to these
filthy horrible vile conditions you
asked the million dollar question why is
it evil and inhumane for governor
desantis to send migrants to martha's
vineyard but not evil and humane when
biden for two years send secret flights
of migrants around the nation there's no
difference there um really interesting
yeah of miners exactly
what an interesting piece of footage
came out griff jenkins brilliantly goes
in front of the vice president's
residence at the naval observatory he
asks an illegal immigrant hey you know
is the border secured the vice president
right there you know over the fence and
the naval observatory says it's secure
his quote is astonishing uh the illegal
immigrant says it's open not closed
everyone believes the border is open
because we enter we are free to enter no
problem we came illegally we did not
come legally so i mean this is the
making of snl skits except it's not
funny at all but to have an illegal
migrant who just crossed the southern
border standing in front of the vice
president's home who just said the
border was secure as he says no it's not
hey i'm here to tell the story these are
the things snl comes up with these
aren't real live things but these are
happening in real life fashion uh with
the mayor of new york saying we're at a
breaking point and he's subject to this
residency requirement where everyone
gets to bed who's homeless except now he
can't even keep up and the activists are
on him i mean this has exposed hypocrisy
to harris's point at an untold level the
shipping across the country of illegal
immigrants to these liberal
jurisdictions that's right david that
stark contrast i can't get it out of my
mind apocalyptic el paso as it's been
called and then martha's vineyard here's
a bed for every one of the eight that
have come here because we can take care
of them that condescending hypocritical
fashion how about just outright lies
let's just go with what it really is
starting with everything from tammy to
what you've all said about this they
want to call uh desantis and abbott
racist for sending illegal aliens around
the country guess what biden's been
doing it for two years he's the racist
but they don't care about this for
anyone that's concerned and i've been
asked this question by callers to my
show by people as i travel around do
they actually care do they actually try
and shift the narrative they just
outright lie because in the end what's
the agenda you you create a problem
that's too big to fix and kamela harris
said that with chuck todd last sunday
she's talking about amnesty again but
they're not even speaking to the illegal
aliens they're talking to the people who
will vote democrat because they face
losing the house they've been losing in
the states they're being taken on by
other democrats and the american people
because we're the biggest constituency
not our elected representatives the
american people see this problem look
harris i hear you we have the ability i
agree we take care of as much as
possible but we're building fences in
uzbekistan to protect their borders and
not protecting our own and we can't
afford this we literally cannot afford
this problem because it doesn't end with
the election cycle it goes on through
the life of the illegal alien when
resources county resources state
resources all taxpayer resources are
used to help that life exist this is the
real cost it's long term it's so
frustrating president trump former
president trump had ideas on how to deal
with this
and it isn't just all on the democrats
who didn't help him get that done there
were republicans who didn't help him get
that done and it wasn't just ideas he
implemented them that's why we had
security for those few years as you know
and that's why it was dismantled in a
heartbeat courtesy of president biden
hey everyone i'm emily compagno catch me
and my co-host harris faulkner and
kaylee mcanenny on outnumbered every
weekday at 12pm eastern or set your dvr
also don't forget to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page for daily
highlights